grab your balls and measure your dicks
or measuring dicks because we're ready
to learn some kung-fu I don't come foo
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into wuis asin's exploring its
cryptic ending and what it could mean
for season 2
so grab your stilettos because here we
go
the ending of whoa assassins starts in
an upscale Chateau in Croatia here we
see the water rude drown a man to death
in order to obtain the final remaining
guideposts to the afterlife we
previously saw the water ruin episode 5
albeit a different actress since once a
woo is killed it will find a new host
unless the woo assassin takes its wujing
now this may sound a little complicated
but we're gonna sort it all out in
episode 1 ying-ying a mysterious
character who helps Kai harness his wu
powers tells us that centuries ago five
warlords corrupted by the elemental
powers of earth water metal wood and
fire waged war against ancient China in
order to stop them a thousand holy monks
sacrificed themselves to empower a
chosen one a chosen one who would become
that woe assassin Kai just so happens to
be the 1,000th warrior to be chosen in
the ongoing battle between the elemental
warlords and the woooo assassin
according to young yang the five
warlords are converging on San Francisco
and the whoa assassin must stop and kill
them once and for all
something Chi isn't too keen on I'm
going home for ying-ying this is
personal the Warlord's not only killed
her but destroyed her world but it's not
clear if the world she's referring to is
ancient China or some other worlds
completely ying-ying was the first to
hunt down the corrupted warlords and she
succeeded after collecting all the
pieces she removed her monk piece the
piece that gives her wuis ass and powers
and combined them into a mystical
tortoise shell why a tortoise shell we
have no idea
taking if the monk piece caused her to
gain back her mortality and she was
later caught off guard and had to use
the shell to protect herself in the
attack the shell shatters causing all
the elemental pieces to scatter around
the
world.this mistake also led to Ying
Ying's death where she was chosen by the
mystical force of the monks as the
mentor our future wu assassins
you see ying-ying lives out her days in
the path a realm between heaven and
earth where the flow of time is slowed
it's here that Ying Ying can pull Kai in
and out of his world and also the place
which aleck McCullough uses to travel
back in time Alec is an interesting
villain were led to believe he's seeking
power in an attempt to take over the
world but in reality all he wants is to
be reunited with his family in episode 5
we see his origin story like Kai Alec
was chosen by ying-ying to become the Wu
assassin tasked with killing the five
corrupted warlords after his wife and
child were murdered by the water Wu he
ventures off to destroy the other
warlords while simultaneously looking
for a way to bring back his family
ying-ying tells him that the power of
being the was a Sonoma death it's the
price to pay for saving the world
just like how Kai ends up supposedly
saving the world but at the cost of
losing his adoptive father six it's only
when Alec kills the wood wu whose powers
include regeneration that he gets an
idea he slits his own throat in front of
the grave of his family which means the
Wu assassin monk piece leaves his body
but since he died holding the wood Wu
piece he is brought back to life with
his family still dead this is why when
ying-ying shows Kai the Hall of defeated
Wu assassins one of the statues is of
Alec Alec thought that with the wood wu
power he could resurrect his family but
that wasn't the case his plan failed and
he's stuck with the power of immortality
the wood Wu's power of healing prevents
aging so Alec is not only forced to live
without his family but forced to live
without them for centuries in his own
personal hell
for reasons that are never really
fleshed out in the show Alec needs to
get his hands on the final quote-unquote
guideposts to the afterlife
a 3,000 year old ancient relic it's what
he tasked the water room not the same
water whoo that killed his family to
retrieve from the old man in Croatia as
we find out in the final episode
Alec's plan is to have all the elemental
wu congregate among the ancient relics
to create a portal to the path kai Tommy
Jen
Alex eg and Lu as well as the other whoo
are all transported there but it's when
they arrive all their powers are taken
from them and their respective pieces
are once again forged into the mystical
tortoiseshell as shall Kai uses to open
a portal that the others can use to
travel back to their world Alec on the
other hand has his own plans he goes the
opposite way intent on being reunited
with his family and it somehow works in
the back lays a blue portal which kai
and Alec used to transport five hundred
years in the past
- when Alec's wife and child were still
alive although for Alec his reunion with
his family doesn't go as expected
Margaret Alec's wife notices something
about Alec and it isn't just his trendy
21st century clothing alec has changed
over the past 500 years he's murdered
and committed terrible deeds something
she's somehow senses this is not the man
she married in one of the more
controversial scenes of the series Kai
having followed alec through the portal
hunts him down and brutally murders him
with his special mizu yaki honyaki knife
a gift given to him by Uncle six this is
quite a change for Kai as in the
beginning of the series he told
ying-ying and Liu many times that he
would never resort to killing secondly
Alec even tells him what's the point
both characters have gotten what they
want why is there need for more
bloodshed but the irony here is Kai's
bloodlust is fueled by revenge for the
death of Uncle six and uncle he himself
almost poisoned to death in Episode five
he believes Alec responsible for the
death of six a death which was carried
out by Jean uncle sixes former
right-hand man who ends up betray him in
order for more power even those on was
kept under the wing of Uncle six it is
uncle sixes restriction of her power
that eventually leads to her betrayal
my son maybe they will assassin
the thought of a big sister living in a
fantasy for uncle six a woman will never
lead the Triad but at the end of the
series that's exactly what we see Jean
has traveled to Macau with the Triads to
meet with the big bosses at the end of
the season Kai opens a letter that has a
photo of zan which is likely her in
Macau meeting with said bosses at first
I thought this letter had something to
do with the one he opened at the
beginning of the episode the one that
Uncle six gave him way back in episode
three but it's not let's take a moment
to examine that letter what was in it if
you go back and watch Kai in Six's
conversation in Episode three it's all
about Kai refusing to take up Six's
offer of giving him his own restaurant
six says if something were to happen to
him to open this letter so my best guess
is that this is six handing over the
rights to his restaurant something kai
originally didn't want to take because
of its association with triad blood
money
kai and six have something of an odd
relationship six took Kai under his wing
when he found him in a shipping
container with his dead father in it
over the years he became a father figure
to Kai even calling Kai his son six was
also protective of Kai wen Kai was
forced to shoot a rival gang member
six grabbed the gun and did it for him
he also agreed to kai to take the goop
poison in order to get the fire root
piece out of him he was willing to give
up all his power for Kai Six's character
is both evil and good something kind
knows and struggles with as six says
there are no true heroes or villains we
are put two sides of the same coin Kai
himself has also somewhat turned into a
villain killing alec and even holding
his wife hostage almost ready to kill
her it's this decision that weighs
heavily on his mind when the Showtime
jumps back to master woz and Kai works
in the kitchen he looks at the
reflection of himself in the sword
almost as if to say what have I become
the odd thing here is that we never see
how Kai got back to the real world that
is if this whole end segment is even
part of the real world we see Kai
celebrate with his friends and
everything seems normal until the
arrival of ying-ying as we know
ying-ying can't exist in the real world
even though when she reintroduces
herself she says the
being in the flesh the world around
begins to collapse but ying-ying seems
unfazed hinting that what is happening
here isn't reality to understand this
better we must go back to episode 9
where the monk tells Kai that if alec is
successful with his plan it will have
catastrophic consequences for all of
humanity Alec going back in time would
disrupt the flow of the Dao causing time
space and reality to become out of
balance that's what I think has happened
here I would not be surprised if in
season two we see some more time-travel
elements we already know it's possible
and that Kai would have a reason to go
back in time to save uncle six there's
even a hint that six might still be
alive in the graffiti at the end
although at face value this means six is
still alive in our memories it could
still mean he might come back and with
ying-ying saying that the Wu assassin is
needed again there's no telling what
could happen likely we'll seize on try
to acquire the Wu pieces in her quest
for power unlike Alec who was motivated
by his desire to be reunited with his
family Zhan has no family she wants one
thing and one thing only power if she
can get her hand on those pieces she'll
become increasingly powerful much like
Uncle six did we also don't know if one
person can hold more than one Wu piece
at a time that could make someone like
zan super powerful if they could harness
multiple elements at the same time the
end of the season also introduces us to
a new character Roland on a childhood
friend of Jenny's he asked her if she
ever thought of a career in the public
service setting her character up to be a
rival for Zhan in her quest for power
and eventual takeover of Chinatown if
that happens Tommy will likely take over
master woz as the full owner Seiji and
Liu have their first kiss and both will
likely be joining Kai to take on Zahn in
season two Liu after all has been
keeping tabs on zan and was the one who
gave Kai the photo of her Macao that's
it for this video please give it a like
and subscribe I have more videos on the
way and make sure to add me on Twitter
at thanks Tori whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much